malaria is an infectious disease caused
by a parasite called Plasmodium it is
spread from person to person by infected
Anopheles mosquitoes the parasites life
cycle is complex when an infected
mosquito feeds on a human it injects
parasites known as sporozoites into the
blood these parasites travel to the
liver where they develop into merozoite
these are released into the blood where
they invade red blood cells and multiply
many times they then burst out
destroying the red blood cells leading
to the symptoms of malaria such as
anemia and fever inside some red blood
cells the parasite develops into male
and female gamete asides these are taken
up by another mosquito when it feeds on
the blood
the gamut asides mature in the mosquito
gut and then fuse together to produce a
new parasite this develops into
thousands of sporozoite that are
injected into a human when the mosquito
feeds and so the cycle starts again
malaria affects millions of people
around the world today malaria
infections are restricted to some of the
world's poorest countries in tropical
regions such as southern Asia Africa and
South America however if you go back
just one hundred years malaria was found
in most parts of the world including
Europe and the United States of America
the malaria used to be a big problem in
Europe all the way up into England it
used to be a problem in the United
States Washington DC was a terribly
malarious area and even up into New
England New York Massachusetts there was
a lot of malaria it's now completely
gone so we can eliminate malaria a
simple way to reduce the transmission of
malaria is with the use of insecticide
treated bed nets these act as a barrier
and protect people from mosquito bites
at night as they sleep nets can be
supplied to communities and training can
be given to make sure that people know
how to use them properly
however distribution can be a problem
and many people still get infected with
malaria there are over 200 million cases
of malaria reported every year the main
symptoms of the disease are a high fever
and anemia but severe cases can lead to
life-threatening complications over
seven hundred and eighty thousand lives
are lost each year because of malaria
children under the age of five are most
at risk and on average a child dies of
malaria every thirty seconds the disease
can also cause extreme complications in
pregnant women leading to the death of
200,000 newborn babies each year so
pregnant women can get massive malaria
infections specifically in their
placenta and that causes our reduced
oxygen and nutrient uptake to the
developing fetus which
result in premature birth so you get our
babies delivered early with a low birth
weight or even still birth an abortion
can be caused by these placenta malaria
infections despite the potential
severity of malaria it can be easily
treated with drugs that kill the
parasite the use of simple blood tests
enable the early detection and diagnosis
of the disease anti-malarial drugs can
then be given to shorten the duration of
the disease and prevent further
complications and death a continual
challenge to treating malaria is the
emergence of drug-resistant parasites
this happened with the drug chloroquine
developed in the 1940s in the case of
chloroquine historically we knew that
resistance had first come up you know in
Southeast Asia right on the Thailand
Cambodian border in the late 1950s and
right around the same time it was
reported in the Brazilian Amazon and
then once we figured out what was
actually the genetic mutation that
caused that resistance we were able to
determine that in fact those had been
independent events but the form that
came up in Southeast Asia then spread
throughout the rest of Asia and by 1978
it had arrived in Africa and then spread
over the next 10 or 15 years through
Africa in the 1990s a new drug called
artemisinin was developed but within ten
years
parasites resistant to this drug emerged
in Southeast Asia to minimize the
chances of resistance developing in the
parasite malaria drugs are now used in
combinations rather than a single drug
treatments so there's a lot of anxiety
in the malaria world right now about our
current first-line class of drugs called
the artemisinin because a sort of a mild
form of resistance has emerged in the
last few years and looking what happened
with chloric when looking what happened
with the anti folate drugs the the fear
is that it's going to also spread from
Southeast Asia eventually to Africa and
right now there's really nothing in the
drug development pipeline that would be
able to replace it so if we lose the
artemisinin so we're in big trouble by
looking at the
different stages of the parasites life
cycle it is hoped that targets for new
drugs and vaccines can be identified
genome research is at the forefront of
these investigations a genome when it
comes down to it is a list of all the
genes that are present in an organism so
the human genome gives us the list of
everything that it takes to make a human
in the same way parasite genome sequence
gives us a list of all the genes it
takes to make a parasite so at a malaria
researcher that genome sequence is a
list of targets it's a list of things
that we could develop drugs against a
list of things that we could develop
vaccines against and if you have many
hundreds of different genomes you can
see which of those genes are variable
which of those genes are conserved which
of them are essential which of them some
parasites have and some parasites don't
all of that information is hugely
beneficial to our efforts to develop new
drugs or vaccines against malaria there
is lots of research taking place around
the world
to improve our understanding of the
biology of malaria this research is
looking at the parasite the mosquito
vector and the human host
it is hoped that this will lead to new
interventions for the prevention
treatment and ultimately the eradication
of malaria saving millions of lives
worldwide
you